but these people are people who don't
want to tell the truth about me because
then they have to admit that they failed
next to me so they need to lie about me
and daz had no interest in the truth he
only wanted to just report lies to get
clicks because he only cares about
himself and but i feel sorry for him
watch this video watch this guy i'm not
going to call them feminists because
they're not feminists they're just
[ __ ] man-haters all right
and they are sex they're angry at men
you know why do you know why because
they've dated [ __ ] they've dated
arseholes they've gone to a club and
they've picked the biggest prick in the
joint they've ignored someone like me
who isn't
amazingly attractive i don't have hench
arms i don't talk about my gains i just
enjoy [ __ ] food all right but i'm a
nice guy i'm a nerd all right but you
won't pick me you won't come over to me
i'm not going to call on feminists
because they're not feminists they're
just [ __ ] that's just sad what what
just go what what what's the problem
what am i missing here are they playing
this again do you know why because
they've dated arseholes they've dated
arseholes they've gone to a club and
they've picked the biggest prick in the
joint they've ignored someone like me
who isn't
amazingly attractive i don't have hench
arms i don't talk about my gains i just
enjoy [ __ ] food all right but i'm a
nice guy i'm a nerd all right but you
won't pick me you won't come over to me
i'm not amazingly attractive i'm a nerd
i'm fat i swear to god they don't choose
me let me let me talk about let me tell
you something dez if you're watching
this let me tell you something this is
my friend why is that terminal that's
sad when you're sitting here like i'm
overweight i'm not particularly
attractive but but i'm a nice guy you
know i'm a bit of a nerd
yes
i'm a nice guy too this is what you
don't get
i'm a nice guy too who's not and i'm
yeah who who has enough
self-respect and dignity to take care of
my health
to dress well to be groomed well
to speak like that nice doesn't matter
yeah they they're not going home
with bad men when they go home with me
and the thing is this they get treated
very kindly i'm nice too bro if you
can't control what you're two years
older than him for [ __ ] sake
if you can't control what you put in
your own mouth
to control your own weight you have so
little self-control and women see that
on you and they know that you have no
self-control you're probably a danger to
them you can't control your emotions you
can't control what you eat
and you need to just look in the mirror
like daz he did a real long hit piece on
me he knows it was fake he did a bunch
of lies that's so true though someone
being really fat is like an indicator
that they they just don't have as much
self-control you can't even control what
you're putting in your own mouth i don't
i think they're giving they're giving a
lot of women too much credit and that
they're thinking that deeply about it
but there may be some subconscious level
there i said that in the last video too
that it's not about being the [ __ ]
it's about having the other features of
your life a lot like on top and being a
gentleman girls like gentlemen's i'll
tell you this though a guy could be
gorgeous and rich and
you know
just have everything going for him and i
just don't if you don't feel it you
don't feel it if you're not attracted to
somebody so it's not everything
it's not everything he's got if he's not
it doesn't have if he doesn't can't make
you laugh you know i'm sure these guys
are making you laugh oh yes these guys
are making you laugh in a very nice
restaurant guys this video genuinely
upset me because you can tell he's hurt
deep deep inside yeah he's hurting they
don't choose you because they don't
choose you but why would they but you
think you have something that other guys
don't but what are you doing sitting
there waiting for a woman to walk up to
you go talk to you you know what's
attractive a guy with some confidence
confidence and some hot spot like i
don't want a guy that's just sitting
there like hoping somebody talks to him
that's the real problem you know what i
think when i go up and talk to girls i'm
like there's literally i i convince
myself there's no reason why they
shouldn't want to talk to me and so i
just go up i'll talk to like the most
beautiful girl at the party at the club
whatever and if she doesn't talk to me
i'm like oh you got something wrong with
her yeah
there's something wrong with her exactly
hey i didn't know she was a little she
was in the other class sorry the little
student had that one it's all good i
think she's pretty you don't have
anything i'm a nice guy you've got
nothing over me
yeah
he knows he knows that and he's you can
tell he's sad he talks about it all the
time being sad and stuff so that's the
haters done but it was interesting when
we got when we got banned to see who the
hypocrites were like obviously can we
like start a gofundme for him or
something
personal trainer you know daz you know
what dezz i know you ignored my first
messages i i swear to god i will not
publicize this i will not put it on my
podcast i will not embarrass you on
youtube i swear to god if you reach out
to me
met one on one on my instagram or on my
gitter or or here on rumble if you reach
out to me i will coach you i will help
you because i think you need help and
that that message literally broke my
heart watching you so no hard feelings
bury the hatchet i don't care what you
said about me i don't care what you said
about my brother i am willing to help
you that is a genuine honest message and
everyone watching this please get that
to daz because
it it just hurts me i don't like seeing
men like this i don't like scenes
this is what we're trying to do yeah and
and this is nothing he doesn't realize
is that and good luck if you don't call
me and the reason women don't go with
him he doesn't understand that women
intrinsically see him as a threat yeah
because men like you and i they know we
have options so we have no reason to
ever assault anybody hurt anybody no
reason to be creepy no reason to be
weird we could just be nice with a girl
if she's not interested fine we have
options men like him have no options so
they find him very scary they're like
okay he can't control what he eats he's
very emotional he seems a bit
unpredictable he gets me back to his
house is he gonna let me go he's gonna
see this has his one big chance yeah to
have some sexual intercourse this is the
thing that and women know bro they can
smell it they pick up on it and that's
why you have to make videos like that
that's why you were alone that is why
your girlfriend left you i saw that
video as well don't even play that
because i'm genuinely feeling sorry for
the guy reach out anytime bro i'll help
you out let's move on to more positive
things
what
no it's just so funny how they just like
literally [ __ ] at him so hard and it's
just like but i feel sorry for the guy
yeah
don't even play that video the video of
his girlfriend breaking up with him
because he's fat ugly gets yeah don't
play that one that was posted on x date
it next time and you can find it exactly
i don't drop the link in the chat yeah
[Music]
won't last long